i know there's no reason if you look at
me you'd think i i could be good at
anything i know yeah so it looks like a
carl to me if i if it was
like a carl like i've always wanted to
call it
no yeah
i kind of like that name everybody
i want to call you carl for some reason
like you look like a carl jenkinson or i
would love to play a guy
i would love to play a guy named carl
yeah yeah
that's a name that's kind of dying out
carls were uh i don't know they were
sort of guys guys but they also could be
like bullies or dicks yeah but i feel
like carl is a guy that was like like if
i was in the japanese internment camp
right and you know how they were free
inside the thing right they weren't
chained up yeah
what do you mean what do you mean yeah
yeah they were freaking the cage use
that word yeah but what let's use the
word free yeah they were free within the
parameters of what of tortoises united
states right gave them so you're free
within this area so they were able to
walk around this and that right but i'm
sure they weren't able to get like pure
rice like the good rice the shiny right
the shiny rice the sticky rice the
sticky rice right but i bet you you know
there are guys like carl
right as a security guard at the [ __ ]
internment camp who was an american
willing to risk his own true freedom yes
yes
to to get you sticky rice because he
realized that you were actually chinese
and not just
that you guys weren't responsible for
pearl harbor and actually were suffering
right
under the japanese because the japanese
are kind of the white people of asia yes
yes that's the movie that's not bad
that's not bad i whisper through the
little fans i go like the body
caught him
did that to bruce lee in a movie what
the director would uh and bruce lee
somehow had a dis agreement in one of
those movies uh
the character name that he was trying to
get to they made it mr braithwaith oh my
god oh god what an [ __ ] yeah so he
got mr mr boyfriend
yeah that's how insecure that that guy
was that he had to do yeah that he had
to do that too i if i was a strip writer
for a bruce lee movie i would use words
like cleveland
just really difficult words for him to
say you know
anyway i would go carl carl
and you go yeah that's my name
and i go
i'd say what do you want there little
fella
i know and you're allowed to be like
some of that sticky rice
yes that this sounds like it's written
by a white guy
and then a cute little asian pokes his
head through yeah but like i pug but
carl would you give me sticky rice if
you could find it
i'm gonna tell you this right now uh-oh
there's no [ __ ] way
i could guard people such as yourself
why
because you were just civilians
ah
yeah like i wouldn't want to guard
harden hardcore criminals because i
don't have the street smarts to not get
[ __ ] up but there's no [ __ ] way
i could go to work unless i deliberately
got a job there to try to bring some
sort of humanity to you
wow
see i'm not a bad guy i know but the
thing is i'll break your balls and i
would make fun of you and your prison
guard but i would i would still be
well you would probably belittle me
still verbally got to in a good-natured
way like little guy what's up little guy
little fella yeah little fella what's up
little fella i say a little fella right
and then i have to internalize that yeah
an average side in china about that
i'm internalized and there's way more of
you than there are me so that brings the
curve down right right yeah and you're
all right okay
i feel like you're defending china
were you born there
you are not average height in china
yes you're short for an asian
you're a shazin
you're special you're a short asian i'm
a sh yeah i'm a chaisen
for sure
yeah um great word can i just say
something that was an attack all right
and i want to defend myself real quick
okay is is that when
western culture introduced our foods to
the east the people grew
larger right so in the